can gang warfare in el salvador ever be
defeated a state of emergency has been
imposed to curb fighting between rival
gangs what's the reason for the increase
in gang crime and can the streets be
made safe this is inside story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm hashem
ahal
he calls himself the coolest dictator in
the world president of el salvador
has also been responding to criticism of
a crackdown on violent gangs critics say
the government's get tough approach
being used to intimidate them as well as
to limit the civil liberties of all
salvadorans
more than 22 000 arrests have been made
since borkeli declared a state of
emergency in march international rights
groups say arbitrary arrests are common
and police routinely infringe basic
rights despite that berkeley has an 85
percent approval rate the highest of any
leader in latin america we hear from our
guests in a moment first this report
from john holman
this is the image that the el salvador
government wants to transmit another
suspected gang member of the streets his
tattoos giving away his affiliation to a
criminal band
they've arrested more than 20 000 people
in the last month and a half as they
seek to clean the ms-13 and
barrierweight team gangs out of
neighborhoods they've ruled for decades
but this also is an image of the
crackdown one of many women saying
goodbye to a husband or a son as they
disappear into the salvadoran prison
system here are others
i love you son she's saying
in march after a murder spike the
country declared a state of emergency
that meant people could be arrested
without a warrant the salvadoran
congress has extended that state of
emergency till late may police continue
to round up young men on mass inevitably
along with the guilty human rights
groups say the innocent have been taken
mata andalus told al jazeera her sons
wanted the latter he sells face masks to
hospitals she says and helps her get by
now she's used a quarter of what she
makes in a month at a market stall to
try and free him
i don't know why the president is doing
this to innocent people people that
aren't guilty
fine someone's done something they
should pay but they're not guilty
at least she knows where he is other
women are going from prison to prison
trying to find their relatives look at
the crowd here
and the crackdown goes on in the italia
district a well-known ms-13 stronghold
soldiers question and search everyone
going in and out
but an overwhelming number of
salvadorans approve of president naibu
kelly's actions
we have stopped paying extortion we're
not paying anything now
the gang members have been being seen
they have practically disappeared and
business is flowing
people are no longer afraid to come to
the city center and walk the streets
so many have suffered extortion rape
killing that even if some innocents have
to suffer others believe that's a price
worth paying if they can simply be free
the question is if at the end of all the
arrests confusion and brutality this
will actually work
john holman al jazeera
two main rival gangs operate in el
salvador
the mara salvatrucha is more commonly
known as the ms-13 it originated in the
1970s in los angeles and is estimated to
have 50 000 plus members both male and
female in various countries
the enemy is the barrio 18 or the 18th
street gang it also has its roots in los
angeles and with a multi-ethnic
membership more than 50 000 strong
both gangs are estimated to make
millions of dollars a year through
illegal drug trafficking robbery and
kidnapping to name just a few in a long
list of criminal activity
let's bring in our guest in washington
dc carolina jimenez is president of
washington office of latin america in
manchester colin harding is latin
america analyst and director of latin
form a consultancy and information
service on latin america also in
washington dc hector silva vales is a
salvadorian journalist and senior
research fellow at the american
university center for latin america and
latino studies welcome to the program
karina
how should we characterize the weekend
murders in el salvador are they an act
of defiance by the gangs
their way of saying to the president
that he
zero tolerance approach is not working
there are several theories around why
you know that weekend
was
so tragic and we saw this incredible
spike in the number of homicides
committed allegedly by gun members but
what i think is clear and what that you
know weekend reflects
is that criminal activity uh and and the
power of guns is still a very present
reality in el salvador
perhaps because the root causes of that
violence have no being addressed when a
country implements
what we call in spanish
manoduro policies these are like hard
line iron fist
policies to address citizen security
problems the results is often very short
term and
you know the is the causes that create
or that generate situation of violence
that is spread over a country are not
truly tackled uh so
what i think we saw on that very tragic
weekend uh was
a situation that has not been solved
that could repeat itself despite the
policies being applied right now or
perhaps because of the policies being
applied
right now and they need to have a solid
response but one that responds to a
comprehensive approach to address
violence and that doesn't focus so much
on this you know um yeah iron fist
measures that do not go into the root of
the problem okay
colin so you have president nair
buchelli who has been saying for quite
some time that it's because of his
policy his approach his toughness when
it comes to dealing with gangs and gun
crime that there's been this decline but
suddenly you have this string of
crimes taking place
over the weekend do you see it that way
that the government has failed to
address the root causes of the problem
i think that's certainly arguable i mean
there is one theory which is
a political website um
has
come up with that uh
in fact what buchelli had done he'd
reached a deal with the with the gangs
uh to uh lower the levels of violence in
return for certain privileges uh and
that this is broken down and that that's
that accounted for the sudden spike and
it murders now
he's always tonight buckellis denied
this and there's no
public evidence of it but it does sound
quite plausible because certainly the
the murder rate in el salvador has gone
down
dramatically since you know since it was
the most violent country in the world
and around about 2015 and it was down to
a much lower figure
last year um but i think it's correct uh
what the other previous speaker said
that uh the root causes whatever they
maybe have not really been gone into
that uh having spent lavishly which is
the thing that makes buchelli very
popular with many salvadorians um he's
uh
avoided making any sort of structural
changes and uh
if this deal that he's supposedly made
has broken down for whatever reason
that this may be the the gang's way of
processing against the against his
attitude
we talk about the root causes we talk
about what's happening what the
government is doing who are these uh
gangs uh
but in the meantime hector when you have
62 people killed on saturday the most
violent
day in 20 years in el salvador
could it be could this be a message
particularly from the most
aggressive of all these gangs the ms-13
saying that we are now gaining the upper
hand as far as salvador is concerned
yes i think they have had the upper hand
for quite a while right now uh until now
uh i would say that uh in fact my
thinking is that the whole bouquet
presidency is based in a
pact of some sorts with that with the
two big gangs because
these gangs have held territorial
control over great portions of the
country neighborhoods uh suburbians and
salvador the countryside the big cities
for
25 years now and there hasn't been any
government that has been able to address
that uh these gangs are pretty hardly
embedded in the
in the social uh fabric of el salvador
and the way that not just phuket but
kelly and other politicians have managed
to deal with that territorial control is
by uh making truces or pacting with them
that's that that's this pact
i think there are enough evidences now
that there's an ongoing pact with the
gangs and that is uh
some somewhat um
fragile pact at some points and i think
what happened as carolina said
in the end in black in that weekend is
that the gangs were actually making a
statement something happened we don't
know exactly what happened yet within
that fact uh that uh had a ripple effect
and the gangs that
effectively those were the gang saying
yes we are here we hold the control of
these territories and if you don't
comply with whatever we're asking uh
this is what what's going to happen okay
we are perfectly capable of doing this
anytime carolina so the president takes
credit for
what he describes as an unprecedented
decline in the uh street crime in el
salvador but we all know that this is
something that started in 2015
four years before he comes into power
should he take the full credit for this
or this was the result of a political
process that started way before
neil buchelli i think he takes credit
one week and then he shows the week
after that he has to do something
because
you know what he took credit for is no
longer
uh is no longer happening uh i don't
think i mean i think
hector made a very good point i mean
gun violence in el salvador is not a new
phenomenon
it's unfortunately
thousands of salvadorians have been
victims of you know
gun violence for decades now and they do
control you know important parts of the
territory etc
so the decrease in violence is just part
of a cycle that repeats itself and comes
with having with an increase in violence
because the root causes are not
addressed so i think he can take credit
for
you know
a day without homicide and he will tweet
about it zero homicide today
but then you know weeks later he has to
take that back because homicides are
increasing again so i don't think uh the
administration of nadi buchelli has been
successful at reducing violence
okay colin so for quite some time we had
top salvadorian officials
coming out and saying that they have
been doing all it takes to clean up the
streets until an investigative media
outlet el faro
said wait a second
maybe there is some dodgy politics here
the government is now being accused of
striking a deal with ms-13 and ms-18
what is what it implies perhaps the
government told these groups to stop
killing people in the meantime do
whatever they want to do
just to give credit to the president
that that he's doing good
well that's there's certainly some
documentary evidence has been uncovered
that that some kind of deal of that sort
was that was reached and as i said
earlier the the one theory is that this
sudden spike of violence was because
this deal has broken down for for
whatever reason and this is there as
that's been said this has been making a
statement that look we can turn on the
violence turn on the taps of violence as
one of them put it uh whenever they
whenever they choose and it's worth
noting also that uh
the sudden crackdown that buckelli has
uh has gone in for
in fact a reversion to previous
government's policies a previous
right-wing government the traditional
arena party had a policy called super
heavy hand in which they uh
they flooded the streets with military
and they rounded people up in much the
same way that uh kelly's done and the
effects were
negligible in terms of a long-term
change in the situation hector is this
something that could potentially tarnish
the reputation of
nayu bukheli the fact that right after
those revelations by al-far we saw the
u.s administration uh putting
restrictions and imposing sanctions on
top officials affiliated with the
president
yes and i think this is a developing
story because
yes in fact this whole gang issue has
put uh uh the vukela administration at
odds with the with washington uh as you
know washington has been the traditional
ally of el salvador since uh a lot of
time now and one of the reasons that it
has
become bitter is because uh uh
actually the investigation that del faro
put out was based in great part in
investigations but uh by a joint task
force of uh salvation officials and u.s
officials in san salva so the us is
pretty aware of this and actually the
u.s has asked for the extradition of 14
ms-13 leaders and the buchela
administration well his attorney general
a guy that was named by buchelle has
denied that and the supreme court has
denied that so
this is is is uh as i said a developing
story and will and and have put the
administration at odds with washington
karen and we have here
at the very center of this debate
is two of the most brutal notorious
gangs in
central
america
the mara salvatrucha or the ms-13 and el
barrio 18 or the ms
18.
why why why are they so powerful
in a place
small country like el salvador i think
um
you know
el salvador is a country that hasn't
truly dealt with its legacy
you know
of war
there was a as we know a very violent a
very tragic civil war and unfortunately
you know the process the necessary
prosthetic process of justice and
reconciliation has never been
uh truly you know uh supported by by the
government that that came to power after
they were ended
to that you also have a country that has
you know very very troubling uh social
economic indicators i mean a large
percentage of the salvadorian population
living very marginalized communities and
do not have proper access to education
you know to basic rights and basic
services so countries with that you know
when where you combine that with you
know what is also a very important
part of salvadorian society which is
having a very rich diaspora in this case
in the united states and the diaspora
you know it also been deported in large
numbers in many instances i think you
have a combination for this type of uh
criminal groups to to as you know to to
be born
and we know that deportation have a lot
to do with the creation of the matters
in el salvador
but also to flourish and and and then
you know combating
criminal uh violence with estate
violence it's always a recipe for
disaster and i think it
in the long run
makes these guns uh more powerful i see
your point colin now when you have
gangs
which manage to set up parallel armies
in a place like el salvador maybe taking
advantage of the legacy of the country
itself violence civil war and so on and
so forth
you have others saying that this is just
an excuse by the government the
clampdown itself just an excuse by a
government trying to further clamp down
on
political freedoms and freedom of
expression just just for the president
to further consolidate his grip on power
well it's certainly part of uh kelly's
style political style he does see
himself as a providential figure
he's part of the the populist uh
phenomenon which we've seen in
many different parts of the world uh
when he was elected in
2019 he just swept away they introduced
two traditional parties which had uh
alternated in power for years in el
salvador
and with a great personal following
and he's cultivated his personal image
into the the reverse baseball cap
the uh the constant uh
social media posts uh the traveling
around and uh
addressing crowds and so he's very much
got his own personal brand he was a
former advertising man and knows all
about such things uh
and yes i mean there are uh indications
that he he finds um
democratic controls and and subjects and
so on a little bit irksome and if they
get in the way he's really not
interested in them that's why he's you
know replaced judges with people uh who
might be troublesome with people that
are loyal to himself hector when you
look at the
sequencing of events in el salvador
state of emergency followed by major
reforms of the penal code which
which implies sentences after 45 years
in prison for
gang membership and also you have the
new law which regulates the way social
media operates particularly when it
comes to reporting on the crackdown on
or
on the gangs
people see it differently see it as an
attempt by the government to
build
a dictatorship in el salvador
yes i think actually i i am pretty sure
that this so-called crackdown on the
gangs what it is is a crackdown on
democracy but this has been
uh the the the plan of naibo kelesis day
one i think i truly think that he had a
plan and that plan was to consolidate
our uh uh
amount power over his overwhelming
popularity first part of the plan was to
take control of congress which he did by
popular vote and then take control of
the
the other institutions and then what
this crackdown has has helped him do is
precisely that is uh to finish this path
in which he ambitions
himself as
uh uh to be re-elected in 2024 and in
order to do that uh he needs
that overwhelming popularity to stay as
it is
as long as he's loved by the salvation
people he will be safe in power and in
order to do that he needs to get rid of
uh uncomfortable voices those of
critical journalists or the political
opposition and actually if you look at
the other reforms especially those to
the to the the penal code uh it's
their aim to to to silence those votes
karina we we have running uh short on
time here when you look at the pattern
of the gang violence we're seeing the
same pattern in salvador guatemala
honduras
groups splintering because of the fight
over a territory we've seen that the
barrio 18 for example splintered into
the southerners and the revolutionaries
and something that has the potential to
just to further create more violence and
instability is this something that a
government like salvador a tiny nation
of seven million can handle or this is
something that really needs pan-american
policy yeah i think you know in general
eradicating violence
especially when it comes to these type
of guns that as you very clearly point
out
are not necessarily
a problem of one country but i have
spread to three or more countries
require broad and comprehensive
strategies so i do think we may we may
need you know some regional strategies
but there are definitely things that a
country like el salvador could do you
know you need a comprehensive approach
to tackle this type of gun violence that
includes you know justice reform
independent criminal investigations
community-based interventions and those
things could be discussed and debated if
the president would listen you know to
experts to human rights organizations
and to citizens but i don't think the
president is listening i think the
president is tweeting and and as you
know my colleagues have been saying
amassing more power
for for other reasons beyond you know
controlling and and ensuring that
salvadorians can have
uh a life uh free of fear and and
violence from god okay
colin
what should be the first priority in
places like salvador and central america
in particular the need to tackle
instability violence armed groups and
drug trafficking or gangs because
ultimately as long as those are there
the gangs will continue to thrive
well yes they're all intimately uh
interconnected though they're not i mean
the gangs will turn their hand to any
activity that raises money for them
and extends their
their control of the local communities
whether it's uh arms smuggling drug
smuggling extortion i mean the the
extortion of the bus companies for
instance is is prevalent
throughout central america um so they
you know they they there's no way of
separating the the the two uh just one
other point is that i'd like to point
out is that about whether buchel is
going to listen to
um
advice or
suggestions he's not
not particularly keen on that i mean
he's actually defied the the
international monetary fund over over
his
uh
making bitcoin um
legal
tender i mean has been the first
cryptocurrency country in the world uh
as part of his vision of creating a
completely new country
and so when the imf warned him that
unfortunately we're running out of time
but i promise you that this is a story
that will definitely revisit on inside
story in the near future in the meantime
carolina jimenez calling hardin and
hector
silva avalos i really appreciate your
insight thank you
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com for
further discussion go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside store you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside sorry for me hashtag
here in doha bye for now
[Music]